and blaming the victim you know you go
right to that you go this is the most
sinister
introduction you know ideological
introduction of this idea that some
people are victims and essentially
victims
and only things should be given to them
well one of the real problems with that
so imagine that you have a conception of
pure victimization
well then you instantly have to posit a
class of pure malevolent oppressors
because like where else who else could
be possibly victimizing the pure victims
it has to be complete perpetrators well
that's unbalanced thinking right because
we're all victims in some sense as you
already of history of of death of
illness and we're all perpetrators too
and you have to contend with that
seriously and and that mucks up the
clean categories especially if you want
to be
well pure let's say
easily that's not an easy thing to
manage and you never will quite manage
it
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today to have
talking with me mr michael
schellenberger he is the best-selling
author of apocalypse never
i read this book this morning
it's great it was full of stories so it
was fun to read
each chapter is extremely densely packed
with information but embedded in a
really compel compelling micro
narratives that make up a really nice
narrative across the whole book it's
counter-intuitive it's full of
information and well that is what
counter-intuitive means full of
information you wouldn't expect it's
very optimistic in its tone just like
despite being realistic it's practical
uh sensible it's a hell of a thing to
accomplish he's also the author of the
forthcoming forthcoming book san
francisco
he's a time magazine hero of the
environment and green book award winner
he's also founder and president of
environmental progress based in berkeley
california and i thought today we'd
probably center our discussion around
this book
apocalypse never although i'd also like
to talk a bit about san francisco and
so what does it mean that you're a time
magazine hero of the environment and
what's a green book award winner
well thanks for having me on jordan uh
yeah those awards were given in 2008 for
uh the first book i did which was
co-authored
and it's a book it was a book called
breakthrough from the death of
environmentalism to the politics of
possibility
and there's parts of that book i still
really agree with one of the themes of
my work is that
environmentalism is depressing it's
actually bad for mental health i think
that's now being proven quite
dramatically with rising levels of
anxiety and depression and reports by
school children around the world that
they're having nightmares about climate
change you may know that half of all
people surveyed say that they think
climate change could result in the
extinction of humankind
my views have evolved over the years but
i've always viewed apocalyptic
environmentalism
as a problem for people that care about
saving nature for people that that for
everybody and so um those awards came
from that prior book
yeah well the the uh the environmental
activism issue is interesting because at
least in part because it also it seems
to me interferes with sensible policy
making so it's actually self defeating
in a profound sense first of all it gets
people hyper worried about extremely
regulated vaguely formulated problems
distracts them from what the prior art
prioritized issues might be
and
well it's hard to think clearly about
what steps to take to move forward when
you're panicking in a vague and
unpleasant manner so and that it you do
not do that in apocalypse never that's
one of the things i really liked about
it was that in each sub chapter you
drill down at least to some degree to
the level of actually actual
implementable policy so you start with a
story about this group and now i should
ask you first who are you exactly to
write such a book like why do you know
this why should people listen to you
sure
so i've been an environmental activist
for 25 years i've also been i'm also an
environmental journalist i write a
column for forbes
uh this is uh that's my apocalypse
number is my second book um
you know i don't have any formal
qualifications i was a cultural
anthropologist i quit my phd program in
the 1990s because the program had become
too postmodern and abstruse
the the first big essay i wrote was
called the death of environmentalism and
then i mentioned the book breakthrough
i mean you might find interesting that
you know my father is uh is a very
humanistic psychologist in the same
tradition of work that you are in or i
see us in
and i knew that environmentalism was
making me depressed like climate change
was depressing me
and that uh and so one of the famous
lines from the death of environmentalism
which was an essay in 2004 was martin
luther king didn't give the i have a
nightmare speech he gave the ai have a
dream speech and we wrote that because i
was reading i would read books about the
civil rights movement and i would feel
inspired by these stories of heroic
overcoming
and then i would read books by bill
mckibben and other environmentals and i
would feel depressed
and i thought you know something that
makes you feel depressed is probably not
very motivating to make positive social
change
yeah you kind of wonder you kind of
wonder too and this is since we're
talking about psychological issues is
that
it's possible too that that kind of
apocalyptic thinking is much more
difficult for people to escape when they
are in fact depressed and so it's very
difficult to separate out political
beliefs from let's say
emotional state
and so
so that's an interesting issue in and of
itself yeah you know people might object
well you know the crisis is so
gloom gloomy
if you're a realist that of course
you're depressed and it it should be the
case because you know look how
depressing the facts are but
that strikes me as well it kind of puts
the cart before the horse in some sense
is like are you sure the crisis is of
that proportion and then are you sure
that depressing people is precisely the
way to go about it and then last thing
there may be is
i couldn't shake the suspicion
especially in relationship to
environmentalism that
it's contaminated quite badly with like
historical shame and guilt and a certain
kind of profound anti-humanism so
and i mean contaminated by that you know
i've heard environment
say something like well the planet would
be better off
as if it was a being in some sense if
there were no people on it it's like
yeah well um
i'm not so sure i trust people who say
things like that and then don't notice
so
yeah i mean i was i one of the things i
stumbled upon i mean at the end of the
apocalypse never
in the false gods for lost souls chapter
i talk about how
i myself was depressed at a period when
i was drawn towards apocalyptic
environmentalism so i think there's an
interesting question of is apocalyptic
environmentalism depressing or is or are
depressed people attracted to
apocalyptic environmentalism or both of
course
um i stumbled across the work of aaron
beck who you know the founder of
cognitive behavioral therapy one of the
founders
and i was struck that the three
structures of depressed people that he
identified
i'm a terrible person the world is a
terrible place and the future is bleak
that that's the exact same three
structures of the every environmental
narrative so every environmental
narrative is that humans are terrible uh
cancer on the planet uh the world is
going to hell in a handbasket and the
future is not you know the end is nigh
um and that's struggling so that's a
very interesting observation especially
in relationship to your comments about
school children and so perhaps driving
those three uh axioms home
you know emphatically and forcefully
isn't the wisest thing to be doing to
young children and the fact of that
overlap with depressive thinking i mean
beck's no small figure in in the history
of psychological thinking he's also
extraordinarily practical as his
cognitive behavioral therapy and it also
as a what would you say as a
psychological philosophy
or as a branch of medicine even one of
the things the cognitive behaviorists
are really really good at and i did this
in my clinical practice is to take those
vague depressive apprehensions and then
break them down into micro problems that
can actually be addressed and that's
much less that's much less depressing
it's like well exactly why is the future
so depressing as far as you're concerned
like in some detail not vague that
look if you're going to run away from
something because it hurts and it's
dangerous it doesn't really matter if
you have a vague conception of it right
but if you're going to face it and
confront it and and solve it let's say
then you can't be vague about it and and
that's also good for your mental health
that that approach um
orientation is directly linked
biochemically and neurophysiologically
to positive emotions so the process of
decomposing these terrible abstract
problems into solvable micro problems
actually facilitates positive emotion
and suppresses anxiety and so it is very
interesting overlap there and it's worth
thinking about
i viewed writing i viewed apocalypse
never as cognitive behavioral therapy
both for myself but for other people and
in fact the highest praise i received
from people is people who told me that
they were very depressed about the
environment and then they read
apocalypse never and they felt much
better
and so i think you have to do both
things like as you pointed out cognitive
behavioral therapy require his you know
back's therapy was you have to be very
concrete about why you're a good person
why the world is a good place and why
the future is bright you have to be very
specific about it has to be very uh
it has to be evidence-based it can't be
yeah fantasyland has to be actionable as
well yeah oh that's so interesting
because i wouldn't have i certainly
didn't get that sense reading the book
you know that it that although
you could also although
illuminating the fact that the problems
that beset us globally and individually
are actually actionable and aren't so
dismal when you look at them in detail
and are also complex in weirdly
interesting ways
it's not surprising that has positive
psychological consequences i mean i
certainly was pleased for example by
your discussion of plastics um you know
i i've been following the work of this
dutch kid i don't remember his name but
he's built this gadget for gathering
plastic which is quite cool and
and
i didn't know that the evidence for the
decomposition of plastics was as robust
as you described in the book so i
thought hey isn't that good that's
that's that's that's a positive thing to
see and i saw many examples of that in
the book that
that things aren't as bad as we think so
let's go through that let's start you
start talking about this group i think
it's a uk group extinction rebellion and
i kind of see them in some sense as the
forerunners of where we might go if we
regard the impending climate catastrophe
as a doom and gloom
laden existential crisis it's like man
half the people on the planet are going
to die
no
solution is too drastic okay so that's
extinction rebellion in some sense so
maybe you could tell the story about
that
i was going to say they say no no
solution is too drastic unless it's
nuclear energy in which case they're
against it or in case it's fracking in
which case they're against that too and
i get it that right away which is that
why are the people who are the most
apocalyptic the most dead set against
the things that have reduced carbon
emissions natural gas and nuclear by far
the two things that have reduced carbon
emissions the most instead they're in
favor of things that don't work adding a
lot of unreliable renewables onto your
grid making electricity expensive making
societies less resilient climate change
those are all high priorities for the
apocalyptic environmental movement so
it's not just that why why why what's
going on
like well i mean it was so interesting
yeah well i mean i you were on my mind a
bit when i was working particularly
towards the last chapter i go through
three core motivations one is there's
certainly powerful financial interests
that work renewable energy companies i
document how fossil energy companies
have financed anti-nuclear campaigns for
50 years
i also have a the the third it's the
chapter so chapters 10 11 12 the last
three chapters of the book look at the
motivations chapter 11 is more on kind
of will to power a desire for status
for feeling important particularly
places like europe which are becoming
irrelevant with the rise of china
wanting to assert their power over the
developing world you know it's no
coincidence i think that as europe's
power has faded they've become more
demanding to take control of the
international economy in the name of
climate change
and then the third chapter kind of says
you know those are both important
motivations but there's something else
going on which is that apocalyptic
environmentalism is clearly a religious
movement everything about it every every
the guilt the original sin
the apocalypse
the the obsession with food
you know various things about it are
clearly a religion and i'm hardly the
first to to make that observation i
document in fact there's actually good
empirical work documenting that
and so i see the you know rising
secularization um what nietzsche called
the death of god and the nihilistic
vacuum that would be created in its wake
as really the underlying engine for
apocalyptic environmentalism it's a way
to
give meaning to the world
so you know i'm i'm writing a new book
which is going to be called we who
wrestle with god
and
it it
obviously we're thinking along the same
lines and for some of the same reasons
and that
there's this
adage in the new testament that
warns people that they should deliver
unto god that which is god unto caesar
that which is caesar's and of course
that on that statement is built the
notion that separation of church and
state is actually appropriate but i also
think that's true psychologically and
this is part of the problem i have with
the new atheist movement or
that
if you don't have a domain that's sacred
and rituals and and and
to deal
and some understanding that there are
deepest values and that's the domain of
the sacred whether you like it or not
you obliterate that in the name of
rationality and all that happens is that
things that are caesar's now become
contaminated with the religious and
that's really not a good thing it's a
seriously not a good thing so it's
interesting to see you close the book
with that kind of
you know with thinking that's along the
same sort of line and so did you see
that working in you personally that yes
okay how
um
yeah i mean when i was apocalyptic about
climate change you mean yes for sure um
and i came back to my uh christianity in
writing apocalypse never
um but it was also i also became
convinced that by jonathan hade and
others that
that having faith was
rational
so you know that it's actually
psychologically healthy to have a faith
and so i had to get over my own
um
demonization of spirituality or
demonization of faith and that unlocked
the i couldn't finish apocalypse never
actually until i had done that no i
wouldn't i wouldn't have guessed that
again from reading the book because it
it it that isn't obvious just as the
psychological issue wasn't obvious and
that i think that's a really good thing
by the way that should all be implicit
in the book rather than explicit it
makes for a better a less cluttered book
let's say
i wanted yeah i mean i i some of my best
allies stephen pinker michael shermer
are in the new atheist movement and i
really regard them as friends i love
them um and and steve also blurbed my
new book san francisco and so san
francisco and i'm doing a third book
afterwards and all three books are
basically
about the threats to civilization from
within
and that they're on they all conclude um
san francisco looks at the religious
this is you know religious the secular
religion
of compassion and how it's gone
completely crazy
to basically result in greater
victimization in the name of rescuing
victims
and so i'm definitely after i think
we're after the same big prey here which
is
you know um
the threats to civilization are coming
from the most civilized members of
society
who are also the most secular members or
they think they're the most secular
member society and they're in there
they're projecting their needs for
they're constructing new religions yeah
well they're also so you know with the
death of god and this is nietzsche
through jung i suppose because jung was
a great student of nietzsche and
as much as freud for sure
as much as he was a student of freud's
and jung was really trying to solve the
problem that nietzsche posed and that
was his life's work and i think in many
ways he actually managed that uh
pointing out first of all that we cannot
create our own values that's actually
not possible we're not wise enough smart
enough we don't live along long enough
we just don't have that much
intellectual spiritual capacity we have
to depend at least to some degree on
tradition and that brings up all sorts
of problems and that guilt you talked
about like that religious guilt i was
watching guy richie's king arthur the
other day and when the new the king that
the to be king arthur puts his hands on
the sword he has this unbearable vision
of his uncle killing his father the evil
uncle and the evil uncle is a very
standard archetypal trope you see it in
the lion king for example with scar and
the evil uncle is often the tyrannical
aspect of the patriarchy let's say and
you know we all exist in relationship to
that because we all exist in
relationship to this patriarchal social
structure history because we're
historical creatures and then we all do
have this guilt that overwhelms us about
the blood and gore and catastrophe that
got us to where we are our unearned
privilege you know to take a phrase from
the radical leftists it's part of our
existential burden and
the existential psychologists who were
followers mostly of of uh uh
what
can't remember the philosopher's name
momentarily wrote being in time
heidegger heidegger you know heidegger
talked about being thrown into the world
so you're arbitrarily put somewhere your
parents are arbitrary
you're subject to society and this and
you have these existential concerns that
will never go away and one of them is
the terrible corrupt weight of history
and how are you related to that as an
ethical being and the radical leftists
are definitely wrestling with that you
know but in their depression let's say
they can only see the negative aspect of
the patriarchal figure and not the
positive aspect and that's a real
catastrophe because
well
it makes you ungrateful for for one
thing which is not a good idea in a
modern state so
okay well let's go back to extinction
extinction rebellion and so you talk
about this activist group that's highly
motivated to point out the crisis and to
take whatever
steps are necessary but they won't do
practical things nuclear energy for
example that's a really interesting one
and so why why not it is that part of
the contamination of the
environmentalist movement with
anti-capitalism per se or what's going
on there it's like well yeah for sure i
mean i think you yes so in so and this
is also so this is also in my new book
which is why are the the main advocates
for action on the issue opposed to the
obvious solutions the solutions that
have worked that are proven to work
and so yes for sure they're because
their motivation is to destroy the whole
system they view the system as the cause
of the problem and they view anything
that that
distracts attention from destroying what
they view as an evil system
as in some ways participating in the
system so that's definitely right right
yeah yeah i've seen that sort of
thinking really destroy people too like
i've i've seen people literally take
take their own lives because they
thought that way they felt they were so
corrupt that any ambitious achievement
whatsoever in the service of this evil
structure was ethically forbidden
and so it's kind of it's like the
ultimate in pessimistic nihilistic
buddhism and it's also another example
of that global thinking global vague
thinking that does in fact characterize
clinical depression
yeah i mean it's interesting i mean one
of the things i talked about how greta
tunberg the swedish youth climate
activist
condemned nuclear power as um dangerous
unnecessary and too expensive well since
when does she care about too expensive i
mean her she's demanding basically that
we
you know grind economic growth to a halt
in order to reduce carbon emissions
um
you know she
condemns basically any modest progress
as inadequate and yet she comes out
against the source of power the zero
carbon source of power that provides 40
of the electricity in her own country
when our allies in germany have been
speaking out to stop germany from
shutting down its last six nuclear
reactors reached out to her to get her
to say something she wouldn't do it
so the problem is solving the problem
gets in the way of the alarmism the
alarmism isn't just i think journalists
and others misunderstand the alarmism
they think it's a tactic to achieve some
end and so one of the things i would get
from journalists is they would say come
on michael don't you think that it's
important to exaggerate
climate change a little bit in order to
get action well first of all there's no
evidence that exaggerating the problem
gets more action yeah the answer to that
is no
let's not lie okay
i don't care what the reason is here no
no lying especially about something
important i mean it's notable that it
comes from journalists who have become
propagandists effectively and so the
alarmism is the goal like the goal is
the alarm yeah well it okay so let's
okay so let's dig down here in a little
bit so
part of what nietzsche predicted was
that the death of god what the death of
god meant what he described and
predicted was that the death of god
meant the collapse of the highest
unifying value okay so it's become
pretty evident to me that we literally
perceive the world through a hierarchy
of value and we certainly organize our
social communities
inside a hierarchy of value and there
has to be something at the top to unite
us now it isn't obvious what should be
at the top in fact it's so not obvious
that we probably can only think about
that in images we're not philosophically
astute enough to actually conceptualize
it and a lot of the religious enterprise
is the attempt to conceptualize that
thing at the top now let's say it dies
because it's god and he got too abstract
eliaded the historian of religion said
that that happened many times in our
history that the top value got so
abstract it got disembodied and people
didn't know what it was anymore how to
act it out or what it meant and so it
floated away and then
collapsed into competing competing
claims about what should be the highest
value
well let's say diversity
equity
compassion well why shouldn't compassion
be the highest value well
you know that's a reasonable thing to
argue about i i think there's some
credibility in the claim that love
should be the highest value perhaps
there's truth and beauty many other
issues okay so
the highest value collapse we're not
united anymore well then we're motivated
to argue about what the highest value
should be and since it's about the
highest value now now i have an idea
it's saving the environment that's the
highest value
well when you attack that then you
attack my claim to embody the highest
ideal
and so you threaten me psychologically
because that's where i found some refuge
and some ethical guidance
and so i'm not going to listen to your
practical solutions either and then i
haven't examined what other motivations
i might have like well this
anti-capitalism issue that's a
terrible contamination for the
environmentalist movement
so because you're just not going to
solve both of those problems at the same
time you want to dispense with
capitalism invent an entire new economic
system and and save the planet
okay
the part of the problem is they're not
actually sincere about it so they would
suggest nature is the highest value but
when you say okay well here's what you
could do to save nature
fertilizer irrigation attractors for
poor countries right take the pressure
off the forest which is where the nate
where the gorillas and the nature is
using oil rather than whale oil to save
the whales and using nuclear power and
natural gas no no they don't want to do
any of those things so there is a
nihilism there in the sense that the
goal is power itself
there's also no such thing as nature
like you think about that it's like when
you refer to france as a as a as an
entity as a person
so you're personifying it or maybe
you're deifying it to some degree well
that's what happens with nature it's
like nature what is that exactly well
everyone knows it's like an old growth
forest or something there's some vague
set of images but
nature conceptualized in that manner is
actually
a deity of sorts an unexamined deity and
who god only knows what it means i mean
you look at what happened in nazi
germany before the nazis took power
because they were allied pretty tightly
with certain kinds of environmentalist
thinking purity for example very big
pushback against invasive species
for example it's quite interesting it's
like well there is this worship of
whatever it is that nature signifies and
symbolically it signifies something like
well the maternal as put against the
patriarchal so that's in there the warm
embrace of mother that's all in that
symbolic realm there's a great book
about that called the great mother by
eric neumann best book ever written on
that in the 1950s an absolute classic
and it outlines the entire domain of
symbolism of the positive feminine and
so you do see this religious struggle
between
those who are now advocates of the
positive feminine
and detractors of the negative masculine
but it's very unbalanced you know
because there's a negative feminine and
there's a positive masculine as well so
we're all tangled up in that we don't
understand it
i mean one of the interesting shifts
that's occurred even in my own career as
an environmentalist is that all of the
stuff from like the ecotopia the
utopianism the green utopianism the
renewal i mean the harmony with nature
the kind of we're all going to live in
these small self-sustaining kind of
anarchist communities the ewok village
sort of picture that's gone now i mean
greta tunberg actively says that that's
not
they're just they literally will say now
we're just trying to prevent it from
being as terrible we're trying to make
it less terrible so the utopianism
it's still there i'm not saying it's
totally gone you certainly see with
renewables the picture of renewables is
somehow harmonizing us with the natural
world but it's nothing like what it was
in the 70s nothing like earth day was
actually mostly positive i have a lot of
criticism of birthday but it was a
mostly positive picture so what's
striking to me is the disappearance of
even that positive picture from
apocalyptic environmentalism i i
wouldn't have predicted that apocalyptic
environmentalism could could sustain
itself with such a single polarity
without this much more positive romantic
utopianism which was really even there
it was there 15 years ago 20 years ago
but it's somehow gone so you don't get
that picture from from greta tunberg you
well depression depression can be
all-consuming you know
and and you know what another thing jung
pointed out very blatantly he said well
what's really going to threaten us he
wrote about this in the 1950s
is unexamined psychic epidemics and he
meant psychological epidemics and and
their effect on the political structure
because he thought well we've become the
most powerful force on the planet and
now our unrecognized
psychological
what would you call them
our illnesses is good enough
they're going to manifest themselves in
all sorts of ways that are going to be
extraordinarily dangerous given our
power and so so okay so you were
attracted to just a quick note on that
you're corrected to the plastics chapter
i don't think i i didn't quite get there
i didn't my thinking hadn't quite
advanced enough but i kept finding
behaviors that seemed very similar to
obsessive-compulsive disorder orienting
around plastic waste
cases of people who were like just they
had to go out and clean up the waste
they had to sort the waste they had to
separate the waste out you know there
it's an obsession where it's like the
waste has to be in the right containers
and people get very upset when you don't
have it in the right containers and this
insistence of course also there's
something around sustainability as a
denial of death you know i rely on on
ernest becker's great work and denial of
death here
where it's that we got to have
sustainability sustainability creating
an immortality project for people and
then i show of course that the problem
is these efforts to recycle plastic
waste have completely backfired because
we don't it doesn't make sense
economically to recycle plastics you
should recycle aluminum paper
tin cans
aluminum cans but but plastics should go
in the landfill or be incinerated
because they're already a byproduct of
petrochemical industry they're already
down cycled the effort to recycle those
plastics meant that because it didn't
make sense economically the recycling
companies would ship
all of that
all that plastic waste to poor countries
where they would end up in the oceans
i mean this is one of the most tragic
and almost i wish i could say a tragic
comic
but it's like we it's not just like like
plastic is really interesting in
relationship to ocd you know i had
clients who were particularly obsessive
about plastic containers you know yogurt
containers and that sort of thing
because
with any when you have ocd and this also
often
happens to people as they age as well
and can't make the difficult decisions
about when something is no long longer
useful you know so their house gets
cluttered up with things that
hypothetically you could use and the one
person i'm thinking of he had great
ethical
inability
he had he had an inability on ethical
grounds to throw out
yogurt containers for example because
while you could use them to store
something in your fridge and there's so
there is an ocd element to that that's
interesting it's it's an orderliness
which is an element of conscientiousness
that's gone astray and that is
associated with disgust sensitivity so
that's interesting because you also
talked about disgust sensitivity in
relationship to vegetarianism which is
also something that nobody has really
examined interestingly enough
so one of the fun parts of apocalypse
never is that i had never worked on
plastics or meat
and they were totally brand new subjects
for me and they are the chapters that
people
have responded most strongly towards and
they were the most fun for me to write
um you know and so on the me chapter i
discovered this paper by these italian
psychologists and who i interviewed
where they said look they said what
what's going on with vegetarians not all
of them but a lot of them is that they
view eating meat as the contamination of
their bodily purity with the essence of
death
and i was just like well that just i
mean there you go i mean it has it all
right all the denial of death stuff well
it is death too those animals die you
know i mean it's more than a mere
symbolic association and it's part again
part of that existential guilt that we
all suffer with from too because our
life is based on death i heard a
comedian the other day i don't remember
who it was someone harsh like bill burr
probably he said you know i realized the
other day that every day something has
to die just so i can live you know and
yeah exactly and that's a non-trivial
and that's part of the horror of nature
that ernest becker is actually quite
good at detailing and that's a great
book although i think it's profoundly
flawed but it's still a great book um
i'm curious i'd love to know how you
think it's flawed
because he thought that the
that that every reaction to the reality
of death was in some sense neurotic
there was no non-neurotic way of of
responding and these hero projects were
all failures in some sense and so he's a
real freudian interestingly enough in
the introduction to becker's book
which i read very carefully
he
he attempted to bring closure to the
psychology of religion so that's what
becker was up to and he said you might
be
the reader might be surprised that i
don't discuss any of jung's work on
alchemy in a book that attempts to
bring closure to the psychology of
religion but
then he says well he he couldn't
understand what jung was getting at and
just didn't go there and i thought well
you made a huge mistake because the
solution to the problem that you've so
eloquently described is actually in all
of that work
and that has something to do with
well it's too complicated to get into
but eric neumann wrote a book called the
origins and history of consciousness
which is his other great work which is a
real antidote to becker and i say that
with all due respect because becker's
book was great so it's really worth
knowing about that other book because
it's a it's a pathway out of the
darkness and camille pallia
mentioned to me at one point that she
thought that if english literature
departments would have followed neumann
who she was very much aware of instead
of daraden foucault that the whole
history of the development of
universities in the west would have been
altered
so yeah it's very interesting i was
going to say i mean i think that the i
think the becker reading of the the
italian psychologist finding that people
fear the contamination abides with death
is that it's triggering their own fear
of death
that you could say it's guilt that you
know all of this prosperity and our
including meat eating is all resting on
bloody horror and death and destruction
and that life itself depends on death
but i think becker would say maybe he's
wrong i don't know but it's interesting
to sort of say really it's reminding
people that they too will die it's not
just that you feel guilty for having
killed something it's a reminder that
you two will die and thus it's actually
triggering anxiety that you're not
living your life in the way
up to your heart it's also you know it's
also a
revivification of the religious instinct
in a very primordial manner so let's say
you know it became too spiritualized and
then subject to intellectual critique
which was really successful in some
sense and so okay bang the highest
ideals blow apart
god's dead where does the religious
instinct re-emerge well it goes down
into the body and we start to become
concerned about such things as what
foods are pure and what foods aren't and
that's a re
it's it's the lowest level re-emergence
of the religious instinct and so the
cycle starts all over again
so there's no chasing away that
yeah i thought you're going to say
something else which is sort of like you
know traditionally or you know at least
at some some points in history when you
kill an animal
it's a sacrifice that you are doing for
the gods or a more modern version of
that is that you've killed this animal
and you thank god for the animal
a more pagan version is that you'd thank
the animal but nonetheless it's like i
mean grace
which i've
introduced um to some amount of
resistance in my own family but has
become this incredibly important ritual
for me um is to say is to express some
gratitude i mean one interesting
question would be you know it's like
that's all gone
but it's like if it would
would
young people in particular who become
vegetarian feel better about it yeah
well you can atone with grace right it's
like well you've had to kill something
here we killed something you know that
had a life and it wasn't without value
and so we can survive it's like well
what justifies that well we should at
least recognize it you add tone for it
too which is at one that means to bring
yourself into a form of union and what
you're hoping is that the sacrifice of
that creature's life is made justifiable
by the power of the ethical actions that
you're undertaking and that's supposed
to be something non-trivial you know
it's like you have to kill things to
live well is your life worth that or
should you just put an end to it you
know so you stop doing terrible things
that's a real question that really
bothers people like it bothers people to
the point of suicidality these aren't
trivial issues and grace is a very
interesting ritual
at least it unites you in gratitude
yeah i was just gonna say so it's
communion communion taking the body of
christ taking the blood of christ it's a
really important ritual and so if that's
gone and now you just yeah eat what you
want doesn't matter right and then kids
raised in that with that sensibility
doesn't matter and then suddenly it's
like wait a second these this meat was a
living creature a living they're not
able to process it because we've removed
the the interpretive structure for them
to be able to process it in a healthy
way i mean at this point i'm
well it's also not trivial that you eat
the communion wafer
right right so that means to embody it
right in the deepest possible sense to
bring the spirit into your body and
embody it and so yeah all that is
symbolically tangled together in a very
interesting way that needs to be taken
apart very carefully so okay so we
haven't got very far into the book we're
still into the introduction with extinct
okay so
mass extinction half of us are going to
die like by 2070 so what have you got to
say about that
yeah so the claims that were in a sixth
mass extinction are just false
just full stop like sometimes i have a
criticism of something where i'll be
like that's misleading or that's an
exaggeration no the claims that we're in
a mass extinction are false
six percent of species identified by the
main scientific body the international
union of the conservation of nature six
percent are labeled critically
endangered but even those six percent by
the way and i and and i care about the
six percent and i i take actions to
actually try to conserve more of those
species but there's no reason to think
that any of those species need to go
extinct we can save those species from
an extinction but a mass extinction
is over 75 percent of all species on
earth going extinct well we're not
anywhere close to that
and the main factor behind what kills
endangered species is either killing
them outright often for food or second
using their habitat mostly for
agriculture since humans use
humans use half of the
ice-free surface of the earth
and of that half over 95 percent of it
is for food production half of that half
one quarter of the ice cream service is
just for meat production well here you
have maybe the biggest piece of good
news
is that the amount of land that humans
use for meat production has declined by
an area 80 percent the size of brazil
well that's a huge landmass over what
over what period of time sorry since the
year 2000 since 2000 yeah 20 years
yeah and people say how have we done
that well it's pretty darn easy you can
you can you can you can have um you can
produce
a hundred cows on an acre of land or one
cow
like so
so you just concentrate your animal
production there's some ethical issues
that you have to deal with but mostly in
terms of at least cattle production
which is the big use of pasture
um it's been uh there's a win-win for
cow the treating cows humanely as i
document um thanks to temple grand
temple grandin yeah she's really
something that woman she's an incredible
person and um and shows
um what neuroatypical people are able to
contribute to this world in a really
lovely way that they don't need to
become
um uh the the negative side of that
often yeah she says she thinks like an
animal she really believes she thinks
like an animal yeah i heard her speak at
a conference on consciousness it was a
great talk a great talk and she's so
pragmatic and and and she's done a
tremendous amount for animal welfare and
in this practical sense of actually
fixing something right yeah absolutely
yeah good for her it turns out that cows
what they want to live a happy life is
not the same thing as what we think we
want cows to have we think cows need to
have a whole acre of land for him or
herself
cows just need to not be terrified
before they die and they need to be in
clean stalls and stuff like that so
there's a win-win win on
humane animal treatment
land use which is essential to
protecting species
um and and human uh prosperity and
development and this is an incredible
story so the whole six extinction uh
narrative is just false and um i debunk
it the other way it's false as you
alluded to earlier we have seen
biodiversity in many parts of the world
increase but with the rise of invasive
species and you may not want that so
diversity is the wrong metric so in
hawaii
you know if you agree with look this is
a this is a this is a this is
non-scientific issue it's just a
question of what species do you want on
the islands of hawaii do you want the
native species meaning the species that
were there
yeah underneath that underneath that is
also this issue of purity and disgust
and borders it's like well that was
nature
before the invasive species and that
nature somehow allied in your mind with
ethical purity and these invasive
species are somehow aligned in your mind
with something disgusting and and uh
inappropriate and there's an ethical
element to that and you haven't sorted
any of that out in your thinking because
like do the does the islands care
life moves around and that's how it is
and so there's there's a weird
unexamined projection of a religious
issue onto what's hypothetically a
scientific issue and
uh mucky thinking what was defined as
natural in hawaii or in the americas or
anywhere is pre-european so the purity
is pre so europeans are the
contaminators right as opposed to like
the like the the indigenous people who
are manipulating ecosystems at continent
wide levels right through fire mostly
but also through hunting and extinctions
um certainly in the americas but also
really around the world
you have this alteration of ecosystems
by indigenous pure indigenous people
so in any event yeah if you want to save
the species that were in hawaii before
1500 or 1700
that's fine but you can make a case for
that not on purity grounds or spiritual
grounds just because you're worried you
like those species you know there's some
cool bird species that could go extinct
you know on the islands of hawaii if you
don't remove some of the the invasive
the invasives fine you're just
manipulating that environment you're
doing it not out of science there's no
scientific basis for it you're doing it
because
we like those species and that's it
that's i and that's where i get to at
the end of the book where i kind of go
i can't if i if i show you a picture of
an endangered mountain gorilla of rwanda
or the congo
and i'm like i want to save that gorilla
and if you're like i don't care about
that gorilla
that's a clash of values there's no
scientific argument i can make to saving
those mountain gorillas i think they're
really beautiful and amazing and they
remind us of our
of our common ancestors or whatever it
may be
but there's no like that's not going to
be solved by some scientific analysis no
and we still have to even if that is
true we still have to have a serious
discussion at the policy and ethical
level about what
steps are being taken by hypothetically
well-meaning ignorant westerners who
think in a low-resolution manner and
whose thoughts are contaminated by
unaddressed ethical concerns asking poor
people in developing countries to
sacrifice their lives often to protect
animals it's like well first of all that
isn't going to work in the long run
because they're just going to kill the
damn animals and that's exactly what you
would do if you were there as well
and
and they're not you can't just ignore
them and that kind of gets shunted into
the well you know they're human beings
contaminating the planet anyways and so
the animals should come first or
something like that and not helpful yeah
and i don't and as you mentioned i mean
i the there's three main female
characters in my book
my book by the way i was accused of
white supremacy which is now just kind
of like whatever it's just now everybody
calls everybody white supremacy but the
three main characters in my book are
bernadette who live in the congo
and is um suffering these trade-offs um
suparti who left the farm for working in
factories in indonesia and my wife helen
they're all women of color
and they all sort of describe these
stages of development and why the
development why economic development is
good for them
as individual human beings and is good
in and of itself and as it turns out is
actually good for the natural
environment too
yeah this this pla this chapter
sweatshop saved the planet that sub
chapter actually i figured that would
make you a lot of friends so
how does sweatshop save the planet
exactly
how do you justify a statement like that
well i wrote this because in the in the
19 in the late 1990s i was working on an
activist campaign to criticize nike for
its factory conditions in indonesia
and i as i at 20 years later i went back
to indonesia to see how things were just
to see what the impacts were
and my views totally changed um
factories
and this has been going on for 200 years
250 years women move from the farms
where they are basically
servants to their parents you know the
serving class their parents they move to
the cities and it's just
liberation yes the life and working the
factory is really hard i mean it's
terrible not compared to subsistence
living on a farm but not compared to
living on the farm and suparti who's the
factory worker who i profile here you
know she has her own scooter she has her
own home she's like uh in her early 20s
um she can marry whoever she wants i
mean
amazing right she's a muslim um still
muslim but she's she's left behind by
coming to the city the traditional
practice of arranged marriage yeah well
that's part of that unconscious worship
of those sort of ewok villages that you
described and the only person who would
think that subsistence farming is
somehow like a utopian goal is only
someone who's so far removed from a farm
that all they have in their head are
images from children's books about like
fairy tale
villages something like that
because it's just so good
it's like elizabethan i always joke that
it's always the utopias are always like
elizabethan england
you know there's always like a
renaissance fair going on at the same
time and and everyone's you know and and
they're
now you know
there's a kernel of truth in it in that
when you go to africa when you go to
really poor parts of sub-saharan africa
as i did the day before i um saw
incredible endangered monkeys
um you know you're walking through
villages that don't have any electricity
and there was a church service going on
and they started singing and it was i
was just like oh it is as romantic and
beautiful and you know when there's not
electronic radios blaring and whatever
now in that same village infant
mortality is really high in that same
village the opportunities for women are
very low not to mention if you're gay i
mean you can't there's nobody you can't
be gay in those villages you know you
can be killed
so you know there is something that does
get lost with modernity
but absolutely the stuff that you gain
has been completely forgotten and nobody
remembers it i wouldn't have known it
had i not been a radical
socialist in my teenage years and went
to nicaragua to help the san anistas i
worked in brazil to help the anarchist
landless workers movement
and you know you would meet young people
and you'd start talking to them and
they'd be like hey
how do i get to the city
yeah
and it would be like you'd be like we're
trying to create a workers cooperative
here and be like yeah man i just want to
get to the university in the city can
you figure out how i can do that and
that changed me and i and and working
alongside folks as they're clearing
rain forest
oh yeah that's fun i picked rocks when i
was a kid i've tried to take stumps out
of the ground you do that for a week or
two and just see how far you get picking
rocks out of the field that's quite the
entertaining work
so
yeah it makes you much more grateful for
not just your own life but also for this
incredible process uh that we call
development and of which is really just
urbanization and industrialization
so i wanted apocalypse never to sort of
remind people introduce that reality to
people and also to see that it's not at
the case where the the picture people
have is that you industrialize and then
you destroy nature no no it's
subsistence culture at the forest
frontier which is driving the
destruction of critical housing that
means poverty isn't that so cool though
isn't that so cool when you step back
and look at it it's like oh
poverty is causing a tremendous amount
of environmental damage so
if we could make people rich and
make things better biologically let's
say more sustainable and actually the
way to do the latter is to do the former
make people rich as fast as you possibly
can then they start to care
absolutely and then you say that to
people it's like resistance it's like oh
i see you don't want people to be rich
on a healthy planet so what's up with
you exactly if that's bugging you what's
going on because that's a good goal and
it all the the smart environmentalists
i've talked to lomberg is like
at the pinnacle of that
in many ways
they all come to that conclusion
and marion toopey as well it's like well
no no if you look at what happens you
educate women
birth rate plummets and that'll actually
be a problem in 100 years because there
won't be enough people rather than too
many but that happens instantly even in
one generation and so that's the
solution to population control assuming
we needed that and so that's in
alignment with every feminist's goal and
then as you get people out of this slash
and burn agricultural cycle well they
start to be more efficient in their use
of resources and they're not they're not
living hand to mouth and so you make
people rich and they become
environmentalists it's like okay that
isn't what we've been told but that's
how it works i wanted to with apocalypse
never i wanted to build on the work that
bjorn and and others have done i feel
like sometimes
what people hear when they read those
analyses is they hear well you're saying
we should just get rich and then with
our wealth we can buy environmental
quality and i wanted to paint a better
picture of it unpack it i think
cost-benefit analyses have a lot of
good but they hide a lot of assumptions
and i think those assumptions need to be
unpacked for people so the issue is that
how is it that becoming rich saves the
environment well it's because bernadette
in the congo
gets to move to the city and when you
ask bernadette hey would you would you
like to live in the city and have a job
at a factory she's like hell yes is
there one no that's the problem in congo
but but it's not like the picture that
people have which comes apart from marx
you know it's in capital the tragedy
they're not the tragedy of the comments
the dark satanic mills yes exactly this
picture that like these these these
happy subsistence farmers
have been forced into slave-like
conditions in the factories women nine
times out of ten it's the opposite they
would like to go to the cities they're
wanting to go to the cities to get those
opportunities and then when they leave
their their frankly low productive
crappy little farm behind
much of the time it just reverts to
grassland and forests
so they're like so stop crying about the
loss of the family farm i say this
because i'm gonna break my mom's heart
because you know we lost the family farm
in our generation but for many people
losing the family farm is fine like like
they're just like it was terrible you
know for much of the world and then it
reverts to grasslands and forests just
like it has in north america i mean so
much marginal farmland i i know i don't
remember how many more percentage-wise
trees there are in the northern
hemisphere since
100 years ago but it's like 40 percent
and then that's another thing that's
really interesting is that and that you
don't hear much about is that a huge
chunk of the planet has greened over the
last 20 years too i think it's an area
the size of the us it's some staggering
staggering amount of land anyways and
that just never comes up it's like and
the idea i i
didn't know as well until about six or
seven years ago that we're in all
likelihood gonna peak at about nine
billion people and then it's like that's
going to plummet real fast like really
fast by all appearances
and so and we can we can certainly
sustain a population of 9 billion as far
as i can tell without wreaking
environmental havoc especially as we get
smarter technologically and that's
happening so fast that we can't even
keep up with it
you talk about fish farming in
relationship to that for example
yeah i mean look first of all we produce
so much food i mean jordan it's crazy
right we have 25
food surpluses i mean we produce 25 more
food than we need we've never had
surpluses that large of share of total
food production or the total size and
during the same period when we're using
less and less land so we're producing
more and more food on less and less land
this is like one of the greatest human
success stories of all times we struggle
with overweight we struggle with obesity
we struggle with having too much food in
the future we're going to struggle with
having not having enough people in some
countries we already are i mean that
gives me some hope is that you know the
new york times had a front page story a
few weeks ago about how
you know the problems related to not
having to to negative population growth
right to population declines you know we
knew really in the late 60s at the time
when hysteria over overpopulation was
the highest we knew that the the rate of
increase was had peaked and declined so
we really had to put up with another 20
years of just this apocalyptic nonsense
around too many people
my hope is that the same thing will
happen with climate change i mean it's
already happening carbon emissions as
you pointed out have declined in the
united states
by 22
since 2004. why is that what we should
have a little chat about that why is
that because no one predicted this so
yeah i mean natural gas in the short
short version right fracking from
fracking i was very familiar with that
because fracking was everywhere in
northern alberta which is saturated with
hydrocarbons everywhere you know so it
was a big part of the economy and
fracking was par for the course there 40
years ago but it's so and this is so
interesting too from from an economic
perspective when you're thinking about
environmental policy it's like
these environmental breakthroughs did
not come where we expected them to come
and you said you cite an mit uh
scientist on page 105 i wanted to read
this because it's so it's so unlikely
um i think that's
i hope i've got it in the right place
here
oh i won't read it i'll just say it he
says
if you really wanted to
decrease carbon in the atmosphere you
might want to accelerate the rate at
which coal is being burned in india so
let's unpack that because you think coal
and india and lower carbon what what's
that about
this that's carrie emanuel from mit and
he points out that
rising prosperity coal coal powered
prosperity now will result in people
have choosing to have fewer kids
and therefore you'll have fewer people
in the future producing more pollution
um the the this the specifics of how
that works i mean that's basically the
whole story is that prosperity we should
view prosperity as essential to
protecting the natural environment in
part because of declines of population
but also because we end up moving
towards cleaner sources of energy right
once you get away from wood
so wood's really bad then coal well
coal's got a lot cleaner way cleaner as
you point out in your book and so that's
really that's a really good thing and so
but coal isn't as good let's say as
natural gas and maybe natural gas isn't
as good as nuclear now who knows because
that's complicated but it's a
possibility and so you want to get
people away from wood as fast as
possible that's part of that getting
away from zero too right in terms of
economic growth is when you're at a
subsistence level
you don't have enough time to be making
the future better you're just trying to
survive today you can't get off the
ground and for the first time in human
history we could get everyone off the
ground no one would have to be at zero
and to give the radical leftist types
credit at least hypothetically they're
concerned with all those people that are
stuck at zero
well but the environment the unexamined
environmentalism is interfering with
that in very complicated ways and so
it well it's hard to sort this all out
obviously nobody part of what i wanted
to do to go beyond i think some of the
you know the the traditional criticisms
of apocalyptic environmentalism
was to sort of say look there's a truly
benevolent process of energy progress
from wood and dung to coal and
hydroelectric dams to oil and natural
gas to nuclear so we can talk about
nuclear but basically what you're doing
is you're shrinking the footprint the
land footprint required to produce those
fuels to basically zero you know so to
give you a sense of it you know like
coal has at least twice as much energy
as a lump of wood
you go to oil and gas you get a
significant increases plus it's coming
from underground rather than above
ground
or having to destroy whole mountains as
you do for coal you get to nuclear
uranium mining i mean you know this
amount less than this amount of uranium
that amount of uranium provides me with
all the power i need for my entire life
a whole high energy life is completely
available to you yeah one we should have
a bit of a chat about energy it's like
okay what's wealth
that that you want to deliver to poor
people okay what's wealth
energy make energy cheap there's no poor
people why
well because work requires energy and
work produces everything and so if
energy is dirt cheap there aren't poor
people
and so
do you not want to have
no poor people it's like cheap energy
man that's your savior and as you said
if we do this halfway intelligently it's
always al also extremely good for the
planet
so
well but the whole system has to come
down
because i'm depressed so that's not a
very good argument and you know that
depression issue is interesting too
because i thought about depression
technically in terms of hierarchy of
values for a long time so
the serotonin system
when when it becomes depleted it takes
less punishment to stop someone an
animal or a human being and so you could
imagine that if you're depressed let's
say uh
i don't know you forget to uh you forget
to pick something up for for your wife
eh and if you're not depressed you think
oh i forgot to pick something up for my
wife um i shouldn't do that again maybe
apologize but if you're depressed you
think well i forgot to pick up something
for my wife
only a selfish person would do that so
that's one level up i
think i do selfish things all the time
i'm a bad person and people are not good
and the future's bleak and and then
every single
negative issue cascades up the entire
hierarchy until it becomes apocalyptic
that's what happens in depression
you can't buttress yourself against
punishment well and anxiety as well but
technically and that's low serotonin
that's partly why people hate to have
their status challenged because
status
the higher you are in status
the better the serotonin system is at
dampening the response to punishment
because it assumes the environment's
safer so those are all necessary things
to know when you're thinking about your
own thinking you know
and so there's a there's another part of
that depression sequence which is also
like somehow the world is to blame for
me failing to get my wife something for
her birthday there's some sort of
external like why i should have had a
there you know something you're looking
for you look at your ex so so the
depressed person goes
because there's something wrong with the
environment you know well one of the
things that also happens in depression
is an increase in volatility and
volatility is tightly associated with
anger and it's under diagnosed
by physicians because
depressed people tend only to be
volatile to people who are lower than
them in the status hierarchy and so
they'll be perfectly fine in the
doctor's office but they'll snap at
their children or their wives and and
and externalize some of that so part of
emotional dysregulation
this is a week this is the psychological
concept of displacement
and this was not my insight but the
insight of um of of some of other in
fact of psychologists hired by the us
government in the in the early 70s they
found that baby boomers were displacing
their anger at a world of nuclear
weapons
i mean i know you've written on this too
um and i certainly um i'm uh i grew up
uh you know a gen xer and when i was 12
years old i was subjected to this
apocalyptic nuclear movie about nuclear
weapons called the day after that was 85
i think okay are you 82 82 80 yeah yeah
yeah
yeah 83
and so you can't do anything about the
nuclear weapons we can't we've i mean
we've a lot of reasons why but basically
we know that you know if one if two
countries got rid of the nuclear weapons
and then went to war the first thing
they would do is reconstruct their
nuclear weapon so everyone sort of had
this sense so then we displaced our or
scapegoat our
fears
of nuclear weapons onto nuclear power
plants and so the move they see the
pro-nu the anti-nuclear movement
makes this shift in the 70s
where they stop trying to i mean they
don't totally stop but they know they
can't get rid of nuclear weapons so they
start to try to get rid of nuclear power
plants and i thought that was one of the
most interesting cases of kind of
collective displacement i interviewed
folks about and asked if it was
conscious
and they everyone said no it wasn't like
they had a meeting and said we can't get
rid of nuclear weapons so we're gonna
get rid of nuclear power plants but i
think it's clearly what was going on and
i see i now see displacement which i
think we can can call scapegoating
um maybe fairly um
in a lot of different circumstances
where people are some of its lack of
clarity of thinking right and that goes
along with that depressive tendency as
well
are nuclear power plants linked to
nuclear weapons well yes they're
technologically sophisticated so there's
that linkage you need nuclear power
plants to build nuclear weapons and so
you know and that's all bad because it's
apocalyptic and malevolent and fair
enough but again you need discrimination
and thinking and
we're also at a point where we think
discrimination is always a bad thing
when it all it is when its positive guys
is the ability to separate out what
isn't good from what is good and then we
have to do that all the time
so we we have to be very careful with
that and so
oh sorry you know go ahead oh just one
other point on nuclear you know i think
there's also um i interviewed a close uh
friend
um who
is not totally convinced of
the roles of nuclear and i said um
it sounds like part of what you're upset
about with nuclear is that nuclear
weapons
have stabilized relations between
nations you know uh political scientists
call it deterrence
uh created peace between nations not
just the u.s and soviet union but we now
see it with india and pakistan
and that really that peace was created
through a bomb
rather than through rationality and
brotherly love and she was very she's a
very sophisticated person and she said
yeah that's you got it of course that's
depressing
that it was the bomb that achieved peace
rather than
well it's not that depressing because
partly look i think around 1983
we all made a collective decision that
things were good enough so we shouldn't
blow ourselves up
i think that was lurking under the
surface ever since world war ii it's
like well maybe we should just call the
whole thing off and burn everything to
the ground
you know and you see that you think oh
no that didn't happen it's like well
these these people like stella and and
hitler like i really think hitler's
fundamental motivation was to see europe
destroyed and in flames he got exactly
what you know world domination and
utopia for germany well look
there's this
psychoanalytic adage if you don't
understand the motivation look at the
consequences and infer the motivation
hitler committed suicide in a bunker
while berlin burned and europe was in
flames it's like yeah that's pretty much
exactly what he was aiming for why
well
that's a good question why
are you so sure the whole goddamn
enterprise just shouldn't burn and the
end of consciousness and all of its
suffering and i think we kind of decided
well
no that maybe that's a premature
judgment we could still make things good
enough so that we could justify our own
existence to ourselves
and the flip side of that is
the reason they created the bomb
was to end a war and to prevent war
that was the reason that you know people
kind of go people condemn nuclear
because they think the motivations were
wrong the motivations were not wrong
i quote neil's board niels bohr the
great father of quantum mechanics
he before the bomb is invented he says
to oppenheimer 1944 in new mexico he
says
this bomb is going to end war as we know
it you know it's going to have to end
war
and and and and but that was why they
were racing to create the bomb is
because they wanted to stop hitler from
building it and then they and then they
themselves prophesied the scientists
knew that it would bring it into war now
i don't think that that made everybody
happy though because i think some people
had a really different vision of how to
end war we know they did which was
through brotherly love and and and
rationality and that didn't happen now
what had when the cold war ends in the
late 80s early 90s it happened a bit
because even people like stalin who was
pretty much as bad as you could get and
still be human
didn't
blow everything up oh yeah so so that is
they're like
in some sense there's some non-trivial
brotherly love and rationality still
operates even in the most right right
yeah yeah yeah but it was for
self-interest um right it was like he
didn't look if you're far enough gone
you'll cut yourself just so you can
bleed on someone else so i think you
make a good point i think you make a
really good point yeah it turns out that
these these lea when we call we call you
know we everybody when they get the bomb
when a country gets the bomb or they're
about to get the bomb
one of the things that we say americans
say is we say well we can't let them get
the bomb because they're suicidal if kim
jong-un gets the bomb in north korea
well he'll he's suicidal well that
turned out not to be the case
you know um so i think that i think yes
i think you're absolutely right um
yeah i was so far
yeah so far yeah yeah and you know and i
would just add two you know it was like
the when the cold war ends and the
threat of nuclear war
goes to very much lower than what it had
been the people who wanted something to
see apocalypse in shifted
from nuclear weapons to climate change
that that's when it occurred and it's
only amazing it's difficult to prove but
it is notable that climate emerges as
the new apocalyptic threat when the
threat of nuclear war declined
significantly and it also yeah well
there is something deep about that too i
mean it's not it's not
accidental
that
the bible has an apocalyptic book at the
end of it it's like this idea that
everything could end and that everything
could fall apart
i mean that's true in life you have
apocalypses in your life all the time
and
and it's very daunting to con to think
about that's hard not to fall into a pit
while you're thinking about that and so
we do have to have a serious discussion
about how to protect ourselves against
unwarranted
apocalyptic thinking that's all playing
out too with the covid issue at the
moment so
human psychological
frailties
we have to take them seriously because
we're a planetary force so
absolutely yeah and i mean i and there's
i excite this incredible book by uh
smile who's one of bill gates advisors
where he actually does look at the
different apocalyptic threats and what
he comes up with as the biggest ones and
it changed my mind too i think he's
right he's like much more worried about
asteroids wars influenzas and super
volcanoes than climate change when you
look at both probability and severity so
i totally agree you should we should
take but i became a much i'm a big i
would like to see more money going into
asteroid collision prevention when you
really look at the history of asteroids
um but so we should take those seriously
but yeah we should also guard against
clearly unwarranted apocalyptic thinking
i mean you know the truth of the matter
is when you really look at the science
of climate change
there isn't
and the ipcc to its credit does not
include any apocalyptic scenarios there
isn't a good scientific scenario for how
the world would end from climate change
like you just have a hard time coming up
with one so you should say that again
because that's quite a striking
statement the i in the ipcc reports
there's no apocalyptic vision
right
they don't even they don't even they
don't even say
when they say more people could die from
climate change what they are actually
saying is they say
if all else were equal meaning
if you didn't have climate change and
you had the same high levels of economic
growth but natural disasters have
declined over 90 of the last 100 years
they've declined 99
in places like bangladesh just through
better storm warning systems and storm
shelters there is no prediction in the
ipcc that more people will die in the
future from natural disasters than die
today that doesn't exist there is no
scientific body that has predicted an
increase
of deaths from natural disasters or an
increase of deaths from disease or the
other things that people worry about
with climate change it's all based on
some idea that yes in a warmer world you
could get
more deaths than you would get if you
didn't have any warming at all but
that's first of all not even an option
and it doesn't account for the fact that
the additional warming is a byproduct of
higher levels of growth
which would right which is going to
mitigate all of that damage and
hopefully have positive environmental
environmental consequences and so okay
so let's tackle another a hard question
another hard question
so one of the
pitfalls i suppose of
apocalyptic thinking and this is true
perhaps practically as well as
psychologically is the notion of a
runaway positive feedback loop right and
so while the green green land ice
pack melts and then the uh the
the currents in the oceans change
because of that especially the warming
current that keeps england from not
being arctic that disappears and that
happens like in two weeks and the whole
damn thing freezes and we're all dead
and so and runaway positive feedback
loops do happen that i mean that's that
that that's not inconceivable so how do
we know when
how do we deal with that say practically
and psychologically well let's look at
the ice first of all so it's the west
antarctic ice shelf that we worry about
are green land so when they worry about
losing those ice sheets it's not in two
weeks it's in 700 years to over a
thousand years that's the period of
which they were they're worried about us
losing those ice sheets so you're
talking about an incredibly long period
of time
now in terms of the gulf stream which is
how i initially became apocalyptic about
climate change in the late 1990s was
reports that the gulf stream
uh would shut down or that you would
stop having the warm
uh air being brought from you know the
warm water and air being brought from
the south to the north um
and that was how i originally got
fearful of it well the first thing you
realize when you read those reports is
that to the extent of which there's been
changes in the gulf stream over history
they've occurred just on their own like
it's just as a natural cycle so it's not
even caused by humans but there is no
evidence that that's being caused by
climate change that that we're at some
risk of of shutting down the gulf stream
i just debunked it recently and some of
the reporters just they it's like a meme
that these reporters will repeat every
10 years or so
and they end up trying to confuse people
about it then i call so the most recent
tipping point study published in nature
as an opinion piece um
must have been 2019 i interviewed the
lead author of it
and it's just a kind of um a bunch of
speculation i mean they this is why ipcc
does not include it that's why it's
actually not science it's not something
that they call science or include in
their predictions and i interviewed him
about he goes and they had this whole
scenario of ice sheets and the gulf
stream and the amazon and i was trying
to figure out how it would how it would
work exactly and then he kind of goes
well you know he goes like the real
problem is that at first they thought
that there would be more that greater
warming would bring more rainfall to the
amazon and then the scientists changed
their minds and now they think it'll
bring less so you have these
so-called feedback loops that we don't
even understand which direction much of
the time they would go in
so you know it's not to say that you
shouldn't
worry i mean you know bjorn
okay so one of the things one of the
things i always told my clinical clients
when they were worried about something
was well you're hyper worried about that
but you're not worried about
a bunch of other things like you're
hyper worried about taking action but
you're not worried at all about not
taking action it's like well where there
might be a disaster lurking there too
it's like there's this notion an
unexamined notion that there is some
safe route
right right and so that's generally not
the case and so
there is a small probability of an
unexpected positive feedback loop and
perhaps that might even be heightened
with climate change who knows there's a
small probability of that but then
there's also the danger of panicking
unnecessarily about hypothetical
positive feedback loops and then
spending a tremendous amount of money
and demolishing things
counterproductively
and and that are you so sure that's not
a bigger danger
and and so yeah yeah so that's right so
if you take it if you take it out of the
climate economics you do asteroids
and you go we should really be spending
much more on asteroids what's the right
amount to spend on asteroid detection
because we could spend a lot more on
asteroid detection well you could devote
the whole gdp to asteroid detection and
then there might be a super volcano
and well we didn't spend all the money
on investigating the super volcanoes or
the same thing could be said for climate
change or an electromagnetic pulse from
the sun which is like a really high
probability event once every hundred
years basically and one took out the
quebec power grid in like 1986 right
knocked the whole northeast out it's
like that could really happen so yeah
there are epoch the problem is with
apocalypses is they're everywhere it's
like so
you know what do we do about that and
that's a hard question but panicking and
producing a panic apocalypse is not a
good a certain panic apocalypse right
that's not a good answer i i actually
worked for a while with a group of
astronauts who were attempting to
uh produce this gadget way out in space
that would nudge asteroids a tiny
fraction of using a huge metal plate
just deflect them a tiny bit and they
would miss the earth and it was a very
well thought out proposal
but it never you know didn't capture the
popular imagination let's say so and
that's also one of the things i kind of
like about lomberg's approach too is he
he tries to rank order catastrophes in
some sense right and cost benefit
analysis does have the flaws that you
describe but you know until we come up
with a better method or i see someone
with a better method uh i'm pretty
attracted to what he's doing it's
practical and i haven't seen anything
better so you know maybe you know of
something better yeah i would just say
the po one another positive way to say
it is you say
we need to be resilient to many
different kinds of catastrophes right
that means that we need to embrace
economic growth and resiliency
because often the things that you're
doing are the same things that you would
do for a lot of different so you want to
have a you want to have a robust
security system a robust detection
system you want to have a good
scientific and technical class in your
country yeah well maybe you stop
terrifying your young people into
depressive neurosis too because the best
way to have a resilient society is to
have people who are
you know
stalwart in the face of the unknown
yeah that's the kind of the bottom of
things
i i just wrote an essay called why i am
not a progressive where i was pushing
back against the recent u.n report which
said no one is safe
yeah
i know it's like we're all gonna die you
know like right
um and i was pushing back into because
you kind of this like that is the
opposite mentality of how you deal with
any crisis any the way you deal with any
crisis or any threat is we can do it
that's yeah that's the only that's the
only thing that we know that works
the idea that oh my god we're all going
to die that's the opposite nobody
why bother if you think everybody's
going to die so that that alone is a
shift i feel like in my generation i
mean
i grew up with the heroes were nelson
mandela you know martin luther king
gandhi you know and we might you know or
even the socialist revolutionaries who i
have significant concerns with but they
their attitude was not
we're all going to die it was not where
no one is safe the attitude was we can
do it now we might not agree with their
utopian projects in many situations but
that's a real shift i think in the last
20 years is this shift and isn't it a
funny thing that that shift has taken
place well things have got so
dramatically better
i mean you know that the degree to which
we've been able to as a as a species to
eradicate poverty essentially all
throughout the world except for when
it's caused by political stupidity is
actually is absolutely
beyond comprehension right and and a lot
of that's taken place in the last 15
years and and the and the speed at which
that is occurring appears to be
accelerating right
and so the anxieties coming from
europeans let's say and elites in in the
united states and canada who are saying
we don't know our place in the world we
used to be at the top of the pecking
order and now china is
right in the united states isn't so sure
where it stands but you kind of go
it's hard not to see
that's the for me i see that as the
connection is that it's like it's like
really the rise of china the eclipsing
of europe's power and so why does europe
elevate greta tunburg
you know a child saying right denied
because they're insecure about their
place in the world they're looking well
and they think they're also wrestling
with something we all are going to
wrestle with is like well what do we do
with our prosperity
like we're not scrabbling around the
dirt anymore and thank god for that
because you know our kids all died and
it was really hard and and so now we can
sit back and think okay well what is it
we're up to well we don't know exactly
what to do with all this pro we should
eat a bunch that's kind of part of the
solution for the last 40 years eat more
and fair enough you know
god
wouldn't it take us like three
generations to adapt to
a surplus of food when has that ever
been a possibility and so we're awake
we're waking up in some ways trying to
figure out what to do with this i mean
europe could have had the attitude is
that now we get to help africa become
rich
now africa africa gets to become rich
and in the process they get to have
parks with wildlife they get to have
both that it's actually not a trade-off
they get to have cities and they get to
liberate their women and and gays and
lesbians can be free in big african
cities as opposed to being persecuted in
places like uganda like that could have
been a project in fact for a minute
there it seemed like it was going to be
you might remember bono had this program
called make poverty history
in the early 2000s it was this idea that
we're going to forgive jubilee we're
going to forgive
the debts of the poor countries and
europe can become developed well and
part of you know part of the reason i'm
sorry african-american developed yeah
yeah well europe too eh yeah
i mean part of what happened to produce
this economic miracle of the last two
since 2000 what's really since 1989
because what happened was the collapse
of communism and and the incredibly
horrible uh consequences of having so
many of those so-called developing
countries fall under the sway of these
you know completely
pathological economic ideas and that
just went away and so part of the reason
people got richer is because we just
stopped doing so many stupid things and
even in sub-saharan africa the rate of
economic development has been
magnificent over the last 20 years
compared to well
in some sense the entire history of
mankind before that and so that that
project is still well within our grasp
and and
it it's hard for people to actually
imagine this and and it was for me too
because i grew up under the shadow of
that nuclear threat i mean all my
friends were apocalyptic to the core
um
and there was real danger there i mean
the keys were in the silos in 1962 at
least once so like we were on the edge
man absolutely and so a lot of us
didn't feel we had a future and and you
know some of that was rationalization
and depression but some of it was
well a real existential problem and now
we could wake up and say
and this is something that's right
we have we can do anything we want now
if we're careful
no more poverty
well there's something man and we could
fix we could help what do you think the
real environmental problems are now that
we should be addressing and
let me let me answer that too by just
saying one thing that i i the one you
hear me pushing back a little bit
because i think you're i agree with you
like the late 80s and early 90s ushered
in this period of great prosperity
because china and the former soviet
union became
um free market democracies and i and and
there was a chance there i think that
the west could have been great now
everybody's going to get rich and we're
all going to have wealth and prosperity
and natural protected conservation
environments
but we didn't the west got um
you know it got it fell into this
apocalyptic um you know radical left
progressive discourse and then my
criticism of the right my criticism of
the cons of really the free market cato
institute right who i agree with on so
much but was that they did turn the
market into something of a god
and so it became a kind of free markets
became valorized as an end of themselves
rather than a means to prosperity rather
than a means to a better future and so i
think that left the so because one
question i you know you have as you i
have is sort of said
how did the right
lose to
this nihilistic apocalyptic
environmental discourse like why is this
why why has the right not been able to
compete with it and i've now had the
chance i testified in front of the
congress six times over the last year
and a half i testified before the senate
and what i find is the republicans
the progressives the democrats and
republicans and progressives they go the
world's coming to an end we have to have
radical action to deal with climate
change and republicans go we need free
markets
and that's not
that's not match it's not meaningless
have you met dan crenshaw
oh yes
i love dan i did dan's podcast i he is
different he's getting he's taking i
mean yeah he's different yeah and he's
on the health committee and the
environmental committees and because he
knows the republicans are weak there and
they're weak can say like and that's
kind of that vague thinking too now
there's a technical reason we don't have
time for this discussion unfortunately
for
you know the
in some sense the valorization of free
markets because they're a cognitive
mechanism but we can like i still
appreciate what you're saying
part of the problem there is that that's
just not a good enough story
and and i mean that in the deepest sense
to counter the powerful apocalyptic
narrative and utopian and
compassion-driven narrative that that
that the left weaves and
and and that's a real shortcoming of the
republicans and par you can see that in
the fact that they can't
talk to young people well except for
crenshaw he seems to be able to manage
that
i agree yeah i think you're exactly
getting out what i'm trying to i haven't
articulated it very well but it's the
idea it's it's that there's a humanistic
message here which is that everybody can
achieve high levels of poverty and
freedom while protecting the natural
environment in fact those in fact the
former is a requirement of the latter
high levels of wealth now people are
going to accuse you of making a freudian
slip because you set poverty oh sorry
yeah high levels are highly achieved
high levels of of of wealth and freedom
and protect the natural environment and
and that is such a powerful positive
humanistic vision and instead what i
often hear is is both um well we just
have to have free markets as though
that's an end and of itself and then
also there's also even worse i hear from
republicans will sometimes say well
china's the one that's really polluting
the planet
you know it's kind of like well china's
developing i mean they're they're also
trying to switch as fast as they can
from coal to natural gas and nuclear but
it's not like
this kind of narrow nationalism so i
think it's this kind of narrow
nationalism the narrow free market
obsession has eclipsed and hidden what
is a really positive bright vision of
environmental human well the other the
other issue with the free market
like i i understand why free markets are
necessary to confront
unpredictable problems it's because of
the power of distributed decision making
and so there's a technical discussion to
be had but what's lacking there is okay
well that's fine but where exactly does
the developing individual fit in that
with regard to their life well
participate in the free market it's like
yeah fair enough but that's a little on
the low resolution side you know and
it's not working to counter this
narrative so obviously it's not
developed enough if you happen to be
correct
you know and so
i've seen something for young people in
conservatism i think
in my experiences linking responsibility
to meaning
and that always when i was touring that
that linkage always left the audience
completely silent it's like well you
need meaning to counterbalance well the
depressive apocalypse let's say
well where do you find it
well if you look at where people find it
it's more often than not in
responsibility and that's a conservative
message it's like and it ties it to
individual psychology and well that's
been somewhat successful i mean i know
there's other sources of meaning art and
music and beauty and none of that's
trivial but a lot of it is well we need
you to grow up and take your place and
the
benefit for you is that you'll find
meaning in that that you can set against
this terrible depressive apocalypse it's
this isn't optional
and so i learned that at least in part
helping guide people away from
depression when i was a clinician it's
like well where do people find meaning
intimate relationships family community
all that and that also underlies that
utopian dream of the walk village no we
want a community that we're part of we
need it it's not optional
and yeah the right hasn't done a good
job of delineating out that so
yeah i mean i wrote about bernadette and
suparti to say
why do you want free markets because
that's what's going to help liberate
bernadette and suparti from oppressive
situations and achieve their full human
potential yeah you did a great job of
that they're really good stories and and
it's so cool that you wove those
narratives underneath all of this you
know you did a wonderful job of taking
all this factual information and weaving
it into a compelling and optimistic
narrative without being
without being naive and
and also well illustrating your
familiarity with a tremendous amount of
information and never really doing that
in a heavy-handed way it's really quite
nice it's easy to read too which is you
know stunning
so hooray for you we're talking about
we're talking about this book here
apocalypse never
and so
um i'd like to also ask you if you don't
mind about
san francisco
what's that what's that about
i'm so excited yeah i just i i literally
got home from europe last night and this
was waiting for me um it comes out on
tuesday
and um
this is a book that is um
the second part of this trilogy i'm
working on about civilization
which apocalypse never was the first
part of
and the book looks at how victim
ideology has is hurting people
specifically it's about drugs crime and
homelessness
in progressive west coast cities but
also the problem spreading
i point out that we have really good
solutions to these problems
including open air drug scenes which is
the technical word for homeless
encampments or these big sprawling tent
cities where
people are using meth and fentanyl and
heroin and dying at huge numbers
while i've been focused on the
environment you know in the 1990s i also
worked on drug decriminalization and
what's called harm reduction
i advocated for needle exchange which is
giving addicts clean needles so they
don't get hiv aids
and when i left that work around the
year 2000
17 000 people were dying from illicit
drugs every year
last year 93 000 people in the united
states died from illicit drugs it's a
complete it's just brutal it's it's it's
barbaric
i'm very angry about this
sad and angry about what's happening um
to the place i live i feel like
i feel
uh responsible and
um i feel like i'm not living in a moral
place i feel like i'm living in a place
that is
depraved where human dignity is being
denied because we're
we're so full of ourselves
we label people victims and then we let
them harm themselves and we let them
harm others because a similar dynamic
which is that
you know because one of the questions is
how did people that say they care so
much about poor people and people of
color and the mentally ill and drug
addicts how did the how did how did
those people
end up with cities where hundreds of
people are dying from drug overdoses on
the sidewalks
every year um san francisco is 713
people died last year
from drug overdoses and poisonings why
are we allowing this when we know that
we know how to deal with addiction right
we have 100 years of experience dealing
with addiction why aren't we doing it
that was the question i wanted to answer
in san francisco why
why does the left care so much about
police killings of african americans but
doesn't seem to do anything or care at
all
about the african-americans who are
killed 30 times higher
by civilians like why what is the
selective
yeah outrage about and so the book deals
really common there's a there's a
question for a t-shirt
what is the selective outrage about
wow man we could think about that for
about five years right and everyone can
apply that to themselves it's like well
you're outraged by some things but not
others that seem equally outrageous it's
like okay
what's going on there exactly
well you can't be outraged about
everything but you know yeah and the
answer the answer is that the
progressives are outraged by what they
see as victims of the system yeah and
then they're just sort of mildly
bothered by victims of other individuals
so why do we let well that's domination
by the great father right that's a
psychological issue yeah that's
interesting
yeah yeah well you know you see these
there's these existential
constants and you know freud said well
god was a projection of the father
that's what he thought all it was just
that and
and i mean he wasn't that shallow but
essentially that's the argument it's
like yeah well there's some truth in
that
well
there's a negative element of that
symbolic image
and and that dominates some people's
life other people are terrified of
mortality itself that's the negative
aspect of the great mother and
we're all
prone to that and we don't understand it
well but
it's there and so the system is the
tyrannical father and make no mistake
about it like there's a tyrannical
father that's the terrible dread weight
of history it's no joke
and
but
but it's one-sided if you're if you're
completely preoccupied by that
especially under conditions of relative
security freedom and all that then well
there's an unresolved psychological
issue there at the bottom of your psyche
that you should attend to before you get
dangerous so
i'm you were on my mind because one of
the there's a there's a mother jackie
berlin late 50s her son is a homeless
addict he could die any day she's been
trying to get him off the street of
course the the city of san francisco is
not helping her the laws are against her
her son refers to san francisco as
pleasure island
and of course i'm so familiar with your
uh
analyses of pinocchio that you were on
my mind
uh while working on this and also the
ways in which
i asked the question of is this monk
housing syndrome by proxy i ultimately
conclude that that's probably too
extreme of a framing but it is
pathological altruism i feel comfortable
with that oh yeah and that's uh well
that's the freudian devouring mother by
the way is pathological altruism so
imagine that you're
you're a manifestation of a maternal
force that says i will protect my
children at all cost
okay so they're in the basement in your
arms
well who's the snake
you
right in that terrible attempt that that
ultimate attempt to make everything safe
right which in some sense is the goal of
motherhood itself right is that you
become
the snake
and i thought about this for a long time
you know and theologically as well it's
like well there's a garden of eden right
and that's the symbolic story and
there's a damn snake in there and it's
like couldn't god make a paradise
without a snake and the answer is no
and no one else can either and if you
don't know where who the snake is it's
probably you
and the whole freudian eatable nightmare
is that devouring element of compassion
which we can't have a serious
conversation about either it's like
too much compassion man infantilizes you
and there's no difference between that
and death it's the same thing and the
freudians to their cred well to their
credit
said the good mother fails
and that's quite the thing i mean i
document how first of all progressives
have just lied about what portugal and
netherlands did
so i've this research shows that
amsterdam lisbon vienna frankfurt zurich
they all did the same thing to break up
these so they have these open drug
scenes where people are using heroin in
public
you know they didn't have the tents but
it was the same thing we have in san
francisco and vancouver
you know really all these cities around
the united states we have the whole you
know the homeless encampments is a
euphemism for what the europeans call
open drug scenes
they all had a period in europe where
they just did the whole social services
offering method on offer would you like
some help would you like some care yeah
no thanks or we'll take the method on
but we'll keep using heroin
it didn't work it didn't work anywhere
and so so and there's a great paper on
this they finally surprise surprise had
to arrest people
you know they had to use law enforcement
and they were and the point was you know
they don't they don't mandate treatment
you have a choice
you can either get off the street you
can't be on the street shooting heroin
in lisbon i interviewed the head of
portugal's drug program i said what do
you do if you find somebody shooting
heroin
in the streets of lisbon he goes they
would be arrested
i was like they would be arrested
because if you listen to progressives in
california or the united states they
would say oh in portugal they just
decriminalized drugs and everything was
fine it's complete
a total lie it's a big lie they arrest
the addicts
they take them to the police station if
they have more than personal consumption
then they get prosecuted if they have
personal consumption amounts and they're
using it in public then they put them in
front of something called commissions
for the dissuasion of addiction which
includes
judge prosecutor defense attorney social
worker psychiatrists your family
so they're using these coercive methods
to compel they don't call it mandatory
you don't have to
you can you can remain an addict but you
can't be on the streets
using drugs and you can choose if you
want to get clean we're going to provide
drug treatment for you or you can go to
jail if you keep breaking the law that's
how it is in all these cities it's
slightly different in the different
cities why don't we do that here
you know and and what i get to the bot
the punch line is because of victim
ideology which says no no that would be
blaming the victim
and blaming the victim you know you go
right to that you go this is the most
sinister
introduction you know ideological
introduction of this idea that some
people are victims and essentially
victims
and only things should be given to them
well one of the real problems with that
so imagine that you have a conception of
pure victimization
well then you instantly have to pause it
a class of pure malevolent oppressors
because like where else who else could
be possibly victimizing the pure victims
it has to be complete perpetrators well
that's unbalanced thinking right because
we're all victims in some sense as you
already of history of of death of
illness and we're all perpetrators too
and you have to contend with that
seriously and and that mucks up the
clean categories especially if you want
to be well pure let's say
easily that's not an easy thing to
manage and you never will quite manage
it
so
well i'm very much looking forward to
reading that book
yeah i mean i'm i'm really attracted to
uh the hero's journey
um i talk about um
you know obviously it's a very powerful
um you know if you believe joseph
campbell it's a it's a it's a powerful
meta-narrative or meta myth for western
societies
in in san francisco the real heroes are
people that recovered from their
addictions
and so in that process they are victims
victimization is a temporary stage it's
a stage in the center of that journey
that you overcome and that is you know
that is the like you know the silver i
mentioned civil rights and gandhi and
you know nelson mandela whatever and you
kind of go that's what those that's what
we're drawn to in those stories we're
drawn to the heroism so that's all gone
here instead it's these people are
victims and only things should be given
nothing should be asked no it's also the
case you know if you know the addiction
literature this is particularly true
with alcoholism but it's not you it's
not uh
unique to alcoholism it's been known
among hard-headed addiction researchers
for like 60 years that one of the
most reliable cures for alcoholism and
there aren't any others by the way
regardless of what treatment center
people say
is spiritual transformation
and in at its base that is
that's a reflection of something like
the hero's journey
absolutely that's a hard-headed reality
and you know you see that happening
pharmacologically to some degree now
with uh what's his name um the people
who are doing the research with
psilocybin showing you know dramatic
effects on cigarette smoking for example
you know psilocybin produces this
mystical experience and that has this
curative
now that's all it needs to be unpacked
it's like it's not just some chemical
thing happening it's very very
complicated way more complicated than we
can possibly understand
but yeah so if you're just the victim
well you're certainly not the hero and
well maybe being the hero is actually
your way out of the addiction because
look at it this way man you need
something better to do than to be
addicted
and that's not an easy thing to find
because those damn drugs hijacked your
your pleasure systems
cocaine
amphetamines heroin the real killer
drugs
they hijack that and so to get out of
that you need something better
well
yeah good luck that happens but
yeah i mean part of the reason i wanted
to write this is i was um after covid
hid all my life plans changed and i
started watching victor frankel videos
i know you love as much as i do i have
two thumbs up for him man i am obsessed
i became obsessed with victor frankel
videos and of course sure enough i
watched a five minute victor frankel
video like five minutes and my i was
like i felt better like it was like it
was like the fastest cognitive
behavioral therapy i'd ever had
ma'am search for meaning oh yeah i mean
so that so he's in the book and i asked
this question because victor frankl is
very popular with progressives in the
bay area and elsewhere very popular
and yet
that in in for personal life for
self-help but then you get to politics
and that's and victor frankl's
philosophy is called blaming the victim
like like literally you kind of go if
you apply victor frankel's because
victor frankel says forget about it it's
all mentality you could be in auschwitz
and it's all about you get your
mentality right and that means you have
to have a goal you have to live for
something something specific and if you
don't have that thing you will slip into
depression
when and you might die in the
concentration camps right so he says you
have to have that goal you have to
organize how is what happened
where viktor frankl is a celebrated
figure in the 1960s i mean you'd come to
berkeley and it would be you know
hundreds of students and just wild
applause from at the same moment
is introduced this idea that asking
vic so-called asking you know victims or
people categorized as victims to do
anything to take responsibility was
itself a kind of victimization how did
that happen that was what i was trying
to figure out how is it that these
things got bifurcated i mean
it's something like
being a mother is good being the
greatest mother is great the greatest
mother takes care of infants the best
possible way
well then the victim is an infant and i
want to be good so i'm going to be the
mother and so and that's great that's
that's a real story you know but it's
half the damn story and and it doesn't
include its quarter of the story
actually it doesn't include the
devouring aspect of infantilization
and so and there's a whole discussion
that has to be had that no one's been
you know
able to have yet about what female
totalitarianism would look like because
we've only had what three generations
four generations worth of experience
with women in the political realm
and we have no idea what authoritarian
with a feminine face would look like
although we might be seeing the odd sign
of it now
i would find this in my research i would
talk to homeless ad progressive homeless
advocates i put it in quotes because i
don't think they're advocates for the
people in some sense they're advocates
for an ideology but they would say
things like
our unhoused population
right and it would just creep me out
well and you got the hand on the chest
right and that's like over the breasts
and that's our you bet you bet yeah it's
like well they don't belong to you
and the whole point is that they
shouldn't be on the street
the whole point is that they actually
need to be liberated from the street
they need to get they need to break
their addictions and live their own
lives but they describe them
exactly as an infantilization
of street addicts and the mentally ill
um yeah well you know you can also
understand that because it to some
degree you know if you work with someone
it's a hard thing to get this right you
work with someone who's got severe
psychological problems there is a
that's that unconditional positive
regard that that roger speaks of and i
think he was
not as clear about that as he might have
been and he certainly didn't always
practice that the way he indicated but
there is this idea that you have sort of
embraced the person you know and then
but you also have to demand a certain
sort of transformation in an upward
direction and that's that in some sense
is getting the maternal positive and the
patriarchal positive balanced
so it's knowing knowing the dangers
it's really the withdrawal of all
demands for taking responsibility
it's basically that any demand to take
responsibility is viewed as an extension
of victimization
and that's just not how they do it in
the amsterdam it's also so it deprives
people it's like there were i i noticed
this again when i was on my tour
particularly you know because there's
this idea for example you can say that
16 year olds are you're just right the
way you are
and that's that maternal embrace right
and fair enough because people have
intrinsic value but it's so depressing
for a 16 year old to hear that if
they're unhappy it's like you mean i'm
i'm good the way i am but i'm so goddamn
miserable it's like no you there's a lot
more to you get the hell up and get
moving and they're so happy to hear that
it's like oh
i'm miserable because maybe i'm not all
i could be yet
and so that's pretty positive and that
does
it's hard to integrate that with the
positive maternal it's well and everyone
struggles with that in their own
families how much do you protect how
much do you encourage
dialogue fixes that in a relationship
and in in amsterdam and which i use as
the best case of how they deal with this
problem
what my the main character um who worked
in the in the open drug scenes he just
describes it all about as positive
relationships between police and social
service workers they work together
every time i would ask them about things
you describe the history it would be all
about how at first the police thought
that social workers were just kind of
fuzzy-headed liberal types and then the
liber and the social workers viewed the
cops as these really terrible uh strict
fascists yeah yeah fascists they got to
know each other and in fact they would
end up taking different roles so the
cops sometimes would be too soft
you know and the social workers would be
too hard you know and they would sort of
and they would and then and now these
relationships last for a really long
time they're not punitive you know it's
rehabilitative they really and like you
said they really believe they have
personalized plans which of course we
get from recovery you know but they have
personalized plans for each person they
really believe in those plans for people
and they're really holding people to
account for them and they're getting so
he always says it's just carrots and
sticks you've always got a consequence
um for bad behavior but some reward for
positive behavior so so your own
apartment is often the thing that people
you know you get in your shelters nobody
likes to be in shelters but
you're rewarded for good behavior with
your own apartment because that's what
people want whereas in san francisco
the the the progressives have insisted
that housing is something that you just
deserve
without any questions asked without any
changes to your behavior
so if you're on the street and you're
shooting heroin or whatever the idea is
that it's immoral to demand any changes
to your behavior you should just be
given your own apartment well guess what
happens in those apartments people have
been using drugs and dying like it ends
up being like a death sentence there's
no one even around to narcan them
anymore so it's this pathetic situ i
mean it's just pathetic like literally
people get narcan they get revived from
death which we know is this moment where
people if offered drug treatment they
nearly died
and there's a moment to really make a
change in your life you know to clean
your act up to get instead we just go we
narcan you and then they're back out
doing drugs doing like you know within
four hours shooting heroin or smoking
fentanyl
it's insane i mean it's it's really a
book that
i mean the process of researching that
there were moments where i just was like
everyone's gone completely crazy you
know and it's not solved by single-payer
healthcare although that might be a good
idea but vancouver is identical in
vancouver as you may know you know it's
identical in seattle and portland and
now it's spreading it everywhere it's in
philly
um
and yeah i think it i i see it as
part and parcel of the most so-called
civilized educated progressive members
of society
doing things that really are not just
destroying you know human lives but
they're also destroying neighborhoods
destroying cities
perpetuating victimization in the name
of protecting victims
well that's a good place to stop i
really enjoyed your book i think it's
great
i really do it was fun to read it was
engrossing it's full of stories and
and it's unexpected it's data rich i'm
really looking forward to san francisco
great title by the way
as is apocalypse never and so
good luck and i hope we can talk again
about
san francisco i think that would be real
good so much appreciated the talk and
and all your work i mean
two thumbs up to you as far as i'm
concerned man way to knock it out of the
park
thank you so much sir it's a real
pleasure to meet you and you were
definitely on my mind for both books um
your work has made uh you've made a
really important intervention
in the culture and you still are and i
appreciate that
ciao man we'll talk again
[Music]
you